foreign
[Music]
Souls like that takes the story of
Pinocchio turns its on its head and sets
it against the Darkly elegant backdrop
of The Bella poke era
finally
we meet
son
you are a puppet created by Geppetto
who's caught in a Web of Lies with
unimaginable monsters and untrustworthy
figures standing between you and the
events that have befallen the world of
lies of P
[Music]
thank you
you are awakened by a mysterious voice
it guides you through the plagued city
of krat
a once lively place that has been
poisoned by Madness and bloodlust
in our souls like you must adapt
yourself and your weapons
face Untold untangle the
unfathomable secrets of the city's
Elites and choose whether to confront
predicaments with the truth or weave
lies to overcome them on the journey to
find yourself
Liza P was inspired by the 19th century
Bella pokera explore the city that may
seem breathtakingly beautiful but in
reality Harbors a terrifying horror
Within
you will encounter various individuals
throughout your journey and lives of
peace
Sophia the guide leads P to save crotch
Eugenie the technician who enhances P's
Weaponry fanini Kratz unparalleled
genius inventor unravel their story to
take a closer step towards krotz secrets
did you know that there are dozens of
weapons in liseope weapons can be
disassembled into blades and handles and
they each hold their own exclusive
motions and attributes
you are able to create your own weapon
to the combination of these blades and
handles of the hundreds of possible
combinations with different respective
appearances performances attack motions
and patterns I wonder which one will
come to fit your combat style the best
some special weapons however are unable
to be separated combined with their
blade or handling sometimes beauty lies
in its Simplicity once you've found the
perfect weapon for you visit Eugenie at
the crot hotel upgraded weapons will be
more reliable when you stand against
your foes
and why is it pee you must be aware of
your weapons durability
weapon durability decreases every time
you cast an attack or block an enemy's
attack be mindful to repair your weapon
from time to time so that the durability
won't hold you back later on oh but
don't fret you can use the grinder
whenever you please to mend your weapon
each and every blade and handle as its
distinctive Fable Arts Fable Arts is a
special combat skill that can be casted
by consuming Babel slots Fable slots can
be charged again through combat select
your own special skills to Vanquish your
enemies
groggy is a system that allows you to
inaugurate stiffness on enemies you'll
notice that the enemy's HP bar
occasionally shines bright upon
attacking this means the enemy has
become groggy available if you strike a
groggy available enemy it will fall into
groggy status
once an enemy enters groggy mode you can
commence a fatal attack and inflict
immense damage if you bump into a groggy
monster make sure to show them who's
boss
if you can't escape it face it utilize
your guard abilities
Guardian enemy attacks will use up your
stamina but it also reduces some of the
damage
the damage taken will be transferred to
guard regain which restores your health
take a second blow before it's too late
Guardian might not be as easy against
agitated monsters that use fury attacks
if you are confident with your reflexes
I suggest you try the perfect guard
successful perfect guard will save you
from receiving any damage even from a
fury attack you can break enemies
weapons or cause groggy status on
enemies through perfect guards
the legion arm is a prosthetic on P's
left arm the legion arm can exhibit
special abilities by consuming the
legion gauge providing you an Eclectic
combat experience the legion arm can
also acquire new skills and abilities
through modification all monsters and
lies of P have their own respective
distinctive characteristics uncover
their combat attributes and use them
strategically to your advantage so
puppets or all there are I highly doubt
that
you have to face all sorts of monsters
huffits only being one of them
you're not quite done yet bone chilling
bosses await you
if a boss seems too intimidating
you might want to get help from a
specter
in Boss matches you can summon a specter
that will assist you in battle
with a bit of help you will be able to
defeat bosses with more use
the PE organ is a system that allows you
to upgrade your character use quartz to
optimize P to your liking within the P
organ you can select which slots to
unlock depending on your preference
decrypting an entire group of slots will
prompt the new set of special Synergy
effects
[Music]
can Gore and style coexist
yes they can throughout the game you
will be able to attain a manifold of
unique costumes
even in the midst of gritty battle don't
lose your style
claim the limited edition costumes only
available through pre-order
[Music]
Liza p in an excellent soundtracks are
truly inseparable
if you're an avid music enthusiast
you'll find yourself heavily immersed
into the game
our developers have also prepared a
special musical treat for you collect LP
to give their enchanting Melody a try
feel all right
just as well
and if you ever stumble upon a telephone
don't miss your chance the one on the
other line desperately awaits you but I
wonder my friend just where you've been
there will be times when you will be
confronted with choices where you can
give Comfort to others and sorrow or
despair by lying or you can choose to
tell the truth
carve your own path
are you a puppet or a human
[Music]
confidence forth
meat lies a p on Xbox One Xbox series
and game pass coming to you this
September 19th
play our demo for Liza p as you wait for
your pre-order to arrive for those who
have pre-ordered you'll get 72 hours of
exclusive Early Access limited edition
costumes and much more
these are the minimum and recommended
system requirements for you to enjoy
Liza P to its fullest extents Liza P
aims for a game experience with over 30
hours of play time and has multiple
endings depending on the choices you
make
what you're seeing right now is the
actual footage of the demo available on
all platforms it is now your turn to
give it a try looking all over for you
may you have a memorable fantastic
experience
thank you
[Music]